哈囉大家好 歡迎來到周慕姿放心說
我是周慕姿心理師
一開始先跟大家聊聊天喔
最近啊 我的課程停止內耗
最近因為就是終於8月底錄完了
然後呢 我們知識衛星的
團隊非常努力的就是剪喔
因為原本我們預計是7個小時的課
現在變成14個小時
而且有可能還會再長一點
我們預計喔 大概會比9月30之前呢
就是提早上我們的第一章
那因為在我現在這個時間點應該是9月20號前
那也許你聽到這一集的時候呢
已經超過這個時間了
你有買這個課的朋友呢
歡迎你可以上去看一下
也許你已經可以看第一章囉
那如果有任何問題的話
可以再聯絡知識衛星的團隊
好的 那現在呢
先回到我們今天要跟大家分享的內容
今天又是十分鐘心理學
雖然呢 有時候我講說
之前我在錄課的時候
我覺得自己發明了十分鐘心理學這個主題
真是人生太美好了
因為錄十分鐘就結束了
但實際上我非常喜歡講十分鐘心理學的原因
是因為有時候我們要花很多時間理解一個知識
並不容易
但是用簡單的十分鐘
帶一個我們生活常常會遇到的問題
可能就會讓你覺得
欸 這個東西怎麼應用到生活
尤其是像心理學這種好像
以前我們會覺得有點冷僻的知識
而這種方式也是我學習心理學的方法
所以跟大家分享
那今天要跟大家分享的這個主題呢
是關於愛情的你追我跑
也就是所謂的焦慮依附跟逃避依附
關於這個主題其實我之前的十分鐘心理學
其實有講過就是一些相關的內容
那今天呢 用比較特別的方式去講
就是我想要用貓派跟狗派
幫助大家去理解焦慮依附跟逃避依附的差別
貓派跟狗派是這樣
你們覺得哪一個是貓派哪一個是狗派
想起來就覺得可以理解就是
焦慮依附就是狗派
那就是你很久沒有回家
好不容易回家的時候
狗不會對你生氣不會對你臭臉
然後還衝過來
這樣子
好 那有可能也是會生氣跟臭臉
但是他就是很激動很想你
他喜歡你不喜歡你
你可以感受到他直接的表現
另外呢 逃避依附當然就比較像貓派
需要自己的空間
就算是就是很多時候他也許很在乎你
或是很想你
他可能還是會很需要自己的空間
做自己的事情
有時候你不知道他在想什麼
很像是你追著他跑
不過在感情中
因為如果是今天是寵物的話
某方面可能還好
有些人還有M體值
貓越冷淡他越喜歡
可是如果遇到感情
你的另一半
你發現你越靠近
對方卻越冷淡越想跑的時候
你不就會覺得很挫折很傷心
覺得他是不是不喜歡我
他是不是不愛我呢
所以今天我們要來聊這個貓派跟狗派
通常都是怎麼面對
情緒的壓力跟相處的方式
所以雖然之前我已經有討論過
焦慮依附跟逃避依附
但在這次呢
我一樣會跟大家簡單的複習
另外帶給大家一些
關於我們之前在講
內耗類型可能會比較偏向哪個依附類型的表現
也跟大家分享一下
首先如果你是狗派的話
也就是你比較偏焦慮依附
焦慮依附呢
這個我們說焦慮依附逃避依附
其實是依附的類型
老實說即使是焦慮依附
也仍然會有比較偏狗的行動
或是比較偏貓的行動
比如說你可能是焦慮依附的類型
但是你的表現
就是你在面對一些互動行為的時候
你還是有可能會比較疏離的
這其實比較複雜
所以我們現在比較是以
就是你表現出來的樣子
比較典型的方式去做說明
那焦慮依附其實有一個非常大的重點
那就是他們的注意力會比較在關係上
也就是對方有互動 有回應 有表情 有反應
這件事情對於焦慮依附是非常重要的
所以呢他很容易把他的注意力
都放在對方的表情
情緒還有他的反應上面
去決定現在這個關係是安全的
還是不安全的
對方是滿意的還是不滿意的
而這個滿意不滿意
會增加他對關係的安全感
因此對方對我有好的回應這件事
對於所謂的焦慮依附就會很重要
因此在內耗類型 討好型 高功能型
就比較多會是
跟焦慮依附會有一些
overlap的一些狀況
但是因為高功能型的樣式也是有很多
所以可能比較常見的可能是討好型
所以對於焦慮依附來說
因為我的注意力都在對方身上
因此對方的一些變化
就會比較容易影響他
所以對於焦慮依附來說
所謂的不安全感
就是對方有很多
我不能控制 我不能猜測
或是沒有給我回應的狀態
他就很容易會有不安全感
因為我的安全感常常建立在對方的回應上
這也就是為什麼焦慮衣服很容易
因為別人有一點動作一點反應
他馬上就會有其動作
而這件事情常常會讓焦慮依附
有時候比較辛苦
接下來 如果你是貓派
也就是比較逃避依附
當然表現出來的樣子
就是好像比較需要自己的空間
而且就算談戀愛一開始熱戀期之後
就會很需要回到自己的生活
做自己的事情
這個跟狗派很不一樣
基本來說
如果是焦慮依附在談戀愛
我說的是典型
典型焦慮依附談戀愛
就是不管他生活工作有多厲害
只要他在談戀愛
他非常在乎對方
他幾乎都會把他的注意力
放在對方身上
但是對於逃避依附來說
在過了熱戀期之後
恢復正常的生活
讓自己可以有空間做自己的事情
我們各自都做自己的事情
對他有非常大的重要性
因為這就是他的控制感
也就是說焦慮依附的控制感
是來自於對方的反應
是他可預期的
而且通常是正向的
這件事情會給他很大的安全感
他可以感覺到對方也跟他一樣
非常重視這個關係
這會讓他覺得很安全
而是逃避依附不是的
逃避依附他在一個關係裡
感覺有控制感
就是他感覺到不會被掌控
他感覺到他還是可以掌控
他的生活 他的關係
然後這一切的東西
都可以按照他的期待跟安排
因此他希望被安排的不是人
他希望被安排的是他的生活
他的狀態
所以在如果對方必須要非常靠近
並且要甚至會讓他有一定的威脅
跟掌控感
那代表他的生活會亂掉
所以他就會覺得
我需要保持一點距離
我需要一點距離做我自己的事情
這跟兩個就是依附類型
他們的習慣有很大的關係
因為焦慮依附是把注意力
放在別人的情緒上
所以當別人情緒有什麼狀況的時候
我立刻去調整
立刻去拆彈
那這個關係就會安全了
所以他的注意力一定在看
哪裡有威脅
哪裡要調整
哪裡要拆彈
大概就是這樣
所以他對於情緒
他沒有那麼喜歡
但是他至少不太害怕
他對於巨大的情緒這件事
但逃避依附完全不是這樣
大部分的逃避依附對於情緒
其實是很害怕的
我說害怕可能有很多逃避依附
聽到這裡假設你有在聽的話
你可能會說我怎麼會害怕呢
我只是不喜歡
我只是覺得很煩
對
因為害怕這件事情
會讓我們覺得脆弱
所以我們會覺得不喜歡或很煩
沒關係 這一類的都可以
總之我就是不喜歡太巨大的情緒
而今天關係太過深入的時候
我會感覺我會被掌控這件事情
也是所謂的貓派
覺得很不喜歡 很不舒服的
因此他們在關係中
能夠感覺到有安全感的方式
就是我可以感覺到
我維持這樣的空間跟關係
你不會因為這樣責怪我
討厭我 不喜歡我
我可以非常舒服的
待在這樣的關係裡
用我自己喜歡的方式
這就會是逃避依附
非常非常重視的一個狀態
所以這件事情就會牽涉到
關於焦慮依附跟逃避依附
他們處理焦慮的方式
焦慮依附處理焦慮的方式
就是焦慮在哪裡
我就要趕快去做些什麼
因此他要趕快去處理
趕快去做
你可以感覺到
狗狗如果感覺到
主人心情不好 很冷
但他可能就會過去
然後想要做很多事情
或是他想做什麼
他馬上就要做
他會很想要靠近
但是比較偏貓派的逃避依附
他們在面對焦慮的時候
他們多半是怎麼處理
你就想想你家的貓
他焦慮的時候會怎麼樣
你如果越靠近他
越想要抱他
越想要處理他
他會怎麼樣
他會越焦慮
他會感覺到壓力越大
他會感覺到你是不可控的
你這個不可控的東西
又要來涉入我的空間
讓這一切變得更不可控
這讓我更焦慮
因此對於逃避依附來說
他焦慮的時候
他並不是直接去迎戰那個
會讓他焦慮的人或事物
他並不是直接去安撫
他並不是直接去處理
他的方式是必須先離開
這個會讓他焦慮的東西
因此他必須退得比較遠
所以這個退的方式
對於如果你是狗派
就會覺得
你如果很喜歡我
你應該要跟我一樣
然後你就會變得更焦慮
你就會更想去追他
因為這是你習慣的方式
而對於貓派的逃避依附
就會覺得
天啊 我就是先需要一點空間
讓我先把我自己的狀態用好之後
我再去回應你的焦慮
你為什麼要一直來找我
於是兩邊的你追我跑就會變得常常會出現
也會讓所謂的焦慮依附
覺得非常的挫折
逃避依附覺得壓力很大
所以回到這裡
怎麼打破循環
其實關於打破循環這邊
我其實講過很多次
不過在這裡我還是很希望
如果今天剛好講貓跟狗派的
這個部分
讓更多人看到這一集
我能夠複習一下
讓大家知道怎麼安定自己
如果你瞭解到
你跟貓派是不一樣的狗派的話
你需要知道
你們在面對焦慮的處理方式
是完全不同的
請不要用對方
他現在有沒有跟你一樣
直接去拆彈來決定
是不是他不夠在乎我
如果他沒來拆彈
如果他沒來安撫我
如果他沒來處理問題
他就是不夠在乎我
不 不是因為這樣
是因為你們在處理焦慮的方式
跟不安全感的方式是完全不同的
所以對於焦慮依附來說
我非常鼓勵你要先學會安定自己
先能夠讓自己不要馬上把注意力
全部都放在
他有沒有回應
這個問題有沒有解決
而是先讓你自己能夠先冷靜下來
告訴對方你的需求
給對方一點時間
去讓你自己能夠消化跟安穩到
一個程度之後
去討論這個問題跟這個狀態
會對你們之間比較有幫助
但是對於逃避依附的貓派
我在這一集想要強烈鼓勵大家一件事
那就是大家可能需要練習
遇到情緒不要馬上逃走
就先撐一下
撐一下然後說出自己的狀況
說出自己現在需要什麼
現在怎麼了
因為大部分的逃避依附
其實是很不習慣說需求的
有很多焦慮依附有時候會抱怨
我有時候會在脆上面看到說
哎呦那個就是
我覺得逃避依附一點都不適合談戀愛
最好就是都不要談戀愛
他們就跟自己在一起最好
但其實這其實是一個很大的盲區是
焦慮依附其實是相對可以說出需求的
典型的焦慮依附是可以用
自己想要被對待的方式
去對待別人
可是逃避依附
他也會用他自己想被對待的方式去對待別人
所以看起來有時候會有點冷淡
因為他自己可能就希望他
狀況不好的時候別人先不要管他
可是逃避依附有沒有需求
有 他有需求
而且有的時候他的需求其實很嚴格
也很難達到
就是因為他比焦慮依附對於人
能夠做到的事情更加的失望
標準更高
所以有的時候他反而不會提
因為他覺得提了如果還是失望的話
他會超受傷
他會更覺得沒有辦法消化這件事
對於就是這個關係的促進跟自己的受傷
他寧願不受傷
他也不要去促進關係
不是說他完全不想促進關係
是在可能會受傷很痛跟促進關係
冒險的情況之下
他會比較容易選不受傷的那一個方式
好
所以當他今天如果在關係中感覺到
可能你們有衝突可能會有壓力
焦慮依附就會馬上覺得說
因為很焦慮之後趕快做些事情
我們應該要趕快談一談趕快做什麼
但逃避依附通常遇到這種狀況
這種衝突跟問題
他的反應多半就是
不做不錯
多做多錯
所以先不做都是沒有問題的
所以這兩邊就會使得他們兩個狀況不依附
焦慮依附就會覺得你好像不需要我
你好像不在乎這個關係
你好像什麼都不用
但並不是這樣
所以對於逃避依附來說
我沒有期待你馬上要說得出自己的需求
但是遇到情緒不要馬上逃走
讓對方知道一下你目前的情況
跟你需要的時間
這件事情對於你跟你的另一半是非常重要的
當你可以成功的說出第一次
而你發現沒有發生什麼很糟糕的事情
你才會相信
你去好好說出你的狀況
現在在你對面的這個人是會聽的
跟你以前小時候遇到的狀態
跟你以前遇到的狀態可能是不一樣的
你必須要有一個機會去證明這件事情
而這個東西會帶給你安全感
這是我想鼓勵逃避依附的事情
好的 那今天10分鐘心理學
你是貓派還是狗派
關於焦慮依附跟逃避依附
我們就聊到這邊
那我們周慕姿放心說
我們下次見 拜拜